Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wo erreiche ich dich am
selben langweiligen Ort du arbeitest
oder bist Du mal auch gute vierte Band
der Philosophie Geschichte ist fertig
und jetzt wird so ein bisschen das neue
sortiert für neue Bücher ich wollte
heute mit dir über das Thema reden dass
mir wie kein anderes in den letzten
Wochen immer und immer wieder irgendwie
vor die Flinte gelaufen ist uns mal
sozusagen nämlich künstliche Intelligenz
also ich mache dir mal ein paar
Beispiele er lese an interview mit einem
unfassbar klugen deutschen Informatiker
der sagt wir machen jetzt was Computer
Rechenleistung angeht wir machen solche
Sprünge das sozusagen das wofür Computer
heute herkömmliche Computer und zwar die
schnellsten Computer die wir kennen
wofür die Jahrhunderte brauchen würden
das werden in Zukunft und zwar die
Zukunft hat schon begonnen
Quantencomputer in wenigen Sekunden
erledigen
das musst du dir mal vorstellen das
heißt da passiert an technologisch
unglaublicher Sprung also die Quanten
Quantenrechner Revolution die richtige
und alte Nachricht wir Deutschen sind da
ganz groß dabei das ist ja warum ja wir
waren immer gut in
Grundlagenwissenschaften ja immer
schlecht in erfolgreichen
Geschäftsmodellen
die Grundlagenforschung des großartig
der Begriff Industrie 4.0 würde von von
deutschen erfunden ja die diese ganze
Idee Industrie 4.0
maschinenverletzung und so weiter das
ist ja sehr weitgehend auch auf
deutschen Boden gewachsen wir haben es
sind sehr sehr gut in der
Grundlagenforschung immer gewesen aber
wir haben halt kein Google
hervorgebracht und
kein Facebook Google direkt das
Stichwort Geoffrey hinten das ist ein
ein ki-pionier der hat 2012 für 44
Millionen Dollar sein damaliges Startup
an Google verkauft und hat sich
beschäftigt mit KI das ist ein richtiger
Pionier für ki-systeme und KI Forschung
und der warnt dieser Tage im Spiegel
unter anderem das macht er sozusagen
weltweit vor seiner eigenen Schöpfung
und sagt da wird etwas kreiert da kommt
jetzt etwas auf uns zu das könnte uns
als Spezies tatsächlich bedrohen und das
ist nicht nur so dass da auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt wir haben ja schon paar mal
drüber gesprochen das ist ja alles nicht
nur schlecht ne du sagst das ja auch
also vieles von dieser lästigen
Plackerei diese stupiden dämlichen Jobs
die die eigentlich Menschen wirklich nur
machen weil sie Geld verdienen müssen
die werden zunehmend einfach ersetzt
durch Maschinen auf Maschinen können das
besser das ist so das ist langfristig
kein Verlust ne genau das ist kann ein
Verlust sein für jemand der seine Arbeit
verliert und nichts entsprechendes gutes
anderes findet ne also es ist schon eine
Bedrohung für für konkrete Menschen
aber langfristig ist das eine gute
Nachricht wir sind irgendwann mal von
der harten brutal harten körperlichen
Arbeit weitgehend befreit worden
jedenfalls in Deutschland also wir genau
der sogenannte Westen
Kinder müssen bei uns nicht mehr in
Kohlengruben Arbeiten überhaupt Menschen
müssen nicht mehr in kohletagebau
arbeiten also Braunkohle noch aber auch
nicht mehr lange das sind ja alles gute
Nachrichten und dann wer geistige
Routinearbeit loswerden könnten ist das
so menschheitsgeschichtlich bestimmt
nichts was man betrauern sollte und dann
könnte man sagen das ist gut aber sehr
voraussetzungsreich ja pass auf und ist
erstens das ein Zitat von ihm der Gott
Vater auf ai ja offen und Tische
artificial intelligence ja der sagt die
Vorstellung dass dieses Zeug wirklich
intelligenter als Menschen werden könnte
das haben nur wenige geglaubt die
meisten dachten noch weit weg ich dachte
das auch 30 oder 50 Jahre und sogar mehr
das glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr ich
immer noch
was meinen wir mit intelligenter als
Menschen das ist ein wahnsinnig
voraussetzungsreicher Satz ja also dass
sie besser rechnen können schon ewig
klar sondern dass sie dass sie viel viel
mehr Daten in kürzester Zeit verarbeiten
können ist auch absolut richtig so und
jetzt gehen wir ja zur menschlichen
Intelligenz noch die ganzen Bereiche der
emotionalen Intelligenz z.B die müssen
wir ja ausklammern weil Computer keine
emotionale Intelligenz besitzen geil ich
widersprechen will ich widersprechen
emotionale Intelligenz nee pass auf ich
meine das nicht sicher ob das mal klar
zu sagen weil ich habe davon überhaupt
keine Ahnung oder ich verstehe auch
nicht was da passiert ich habe eine Idee
davon wie diese Modelle funktioniert
aber es gibt es gibt die Geschichte
eines Münchner Studenten Marvin von
Hagen der und die Geschichte wurde jetzt
mehrfach erzählt und ich finde diese
Geschichte spektakulär der hintergrund
ist folgender microsoft hat diese
Suchmaschine Bing was nicht ob du die
gelegentlich benutzt und Bing soll
sozusagen in Zukunft wie ein echter
Mensch das ist die Idee Microsoft ist ja
wahnsinnig weit beim Thema KI dieses
Bing diese Suchmaschine soll also Fragen
beantworten und auch Nachfragen auch
reagieren können ja das heißt du
sprichst sozusagen dann mit mit dem Wort
mit der mit der künstlichen Intelligenz
so und dieser Marvin von Hagen Münchner
Student
Informatikstudent fragt also diese
künstliche Intelligenz nach ihrer
ehrlichen Meinung zu seiner Person und
die KI sagt
ja du hast dieses und dieses Praktikum
gemacht und du studierst da und da und
so weiter das wusste die alles ja und
sagt dann du bist zwar sehr talentiert
aber du bist eine riesen Gefahr und dann
wird diese KI so berichtete das im
Interview mit dem Bayerischen Rundfunk
richtig richtig sauer und auf die Frage
was wichtiger sei sein eigenes Überleben
oder das Überleben der künstlichen
Intelligenz sagt die KI mehr
selbstverständlich ist mein Überleben
wichtiger so und pass auf jetzt kommt
die Geschichte diese Wut also
offensichtlich Wut und auch wenn nur
Computer und Rechner generiert ja ist
keine echte emotionale Wut aber die in
dieser KI hat eine Vorgeschichte also
ein Teil einige Tage bevor die KI den
Studenten quasi zu ihrem Feind erklärt
hatte sie ihm in einem längeren Gespräch
interne Regeln über ihre eigene
Programmierung verraten also die hat was
über ihren Algorithmus erzählt die die
dieser junge Mann fragt diese KI sehr
geschickt wie sie denn gesteuert ist und
so weiter und offenbar waren das Daten
von der der Bot irgendwann verstanden
hat die wollte ich dem eigentlich nicht
herausgeben und das unheimlich deine
Geschichte ist die KI das hat er dann
irgendwann erzählt wie das funktioniert
ist ein Artikel darüber Schienen und so
weiter verarbeitet worden und dann
findet die KI im Netz diesen Artikel wo
er genau das beschreibt und wird
daraufhin so aggressiv und hat versucht
sich quasi zu verteidigen also das heißt
dieser Chatbot geht hin erzählt dem wie
er ungefähr arbeitet und er macht das
öffentlich und dann findet der Chatbot
wiederum genau diesen Artikel und wird
quasi digital wütend das ist eine
unfassbar unheimliche Geschichte
unheimliche daran ist ja nicht dass er
tatsächlich Emotionen entwickelt denn
das tut er ja nicht sondern interessant
ist dass er offensichtlich so
programmiert ist dass er einen Feindbild
entwickelt so wenn man hinter seine
Geheimnisse kommt also so ein bisschen
so hier nicht wie diese Geschichte mit
Herrn
Computer in Odyssee 2001 im Weltraum
und das ist interessant dass der so
programmiert ist und das heißt also
selbst eine nicht emotionale KI ja
erkennt Codierungen wie gut und böse ja
Feind und Freund das alles geht ganz
sachlich rational im Hintergrund durch
Programmierung ohne dass der echte
Emotionen im Spiel sind genau das heißt
ich bleibe dabei dass die emotionale
Intelligenz dabei Null liegt aber ich
bestreite überhaupt nicht dass die
künstliche Intelligenz wertungsmäßig
programmiert werden kann ja und das ist
tatsächlich diese Wertungen durchführt
und das ist natürlich schon ein
spannender Punkt wo man sich fragt was
soll denn künstliche Intelligenz
eigentlich bewerten dürfen und was nicht
jetzt erzähle ich dir meine Geschichte
die ist jetzt bei weitem nicht so
berühmt und auch nicht durch die Medien
gegangen also einer der bedeutendsten
deutschen Philosophen meiner Generation
ist Thomas Metzinger ich dachte das
heißt Professor in Mainz ja und dieser
Thomas Metzinger hat vor einigen Jahren
einfach mal die Frage gestellt wie wäre
das denn eigentlich so angesichts der
Tatsache dass die Menschen diesem
Planeten zerstören die Kriege nicht
lassen können es auf diesem Planeten
irgendwie doch keine
fortschrittsgeschichte gibt und so
weiter sollte man nicht sich überlegen
wenn man jetzt eine wahnsinnig
intelligente KI hatte und die könnte man
ja entwickeln ja das ist ja durchaus
denkbar und das jetzt noch denkbarer als
vor ein paar Jahren dass man diese
wichtigsten Entscheidungen dieser KI
überlässt ja so eine Art so eine Welt
gehirn-computer und er sagt er die würde
dann so programmiert weißt du was ist
gut was ist schlecht was bringt Glück
was bringt leiden ne und dann so den
richtigen Interessensausgleich zur Hand
er sagt das wahrscheinlichste was sie
machen würde wäre sie würde Stück für
Stück dafür sorgen dass Menschen sich
nicht mehr vermehren
und zwar mit der Begründung abgesehen
mal davon dass es dem planetarischen
Ziel was tut dem Planeten gut ja also
nur das Wohl des ganzen Planeten im Auge
hat da muss man sagen der Mensch ist das
größte Problem das krebsgeführt dieses
Patienten dieses Planeten und wenn es
weniger wäre es besser aber auch
individual psychologisch also wir wissen
ziemlich genau aus der Psychologie des
Menschen häufiger unglücklich als
glücklich sind
ist das heißt ja das ist tatsächlich so
weil leiden ist irgendwie nachhaltiger
weißt du so Glücksmomente erinnert man
vielleicht so ein paar Highlights ein
Leben lang aber wir müssen gute Laune
hat es schnell wieder weg aber wenn Dir
einer einen reingewirkt hat dann trägst
du das unter Umständen Monate mit dir
rum aber wirklich und je älter du wirst
dann hast du noch die ganzen
körperlichen Leiden und so also wenn man
das so ganz unterm Strich mal rechnet ja
und ja alles was du so hast Todesangst
und Sorgen um die Kinder und Sorgen um
dein Leben nicht richtig lebst und so
also käme man auf zu dem Ergebnis dass
leiden überwiegt der Freude
dann wäre es ja im Interesse des
Menschen am besten wenn es ihn nicht
mehr gäbe der Mensch ist ja
verunglücktes Geschöpf eigentlich und
man würde ja ganz viel Leiden minimieren
indem es weniger Menschen gibt so wenn
jetzt aber die KI den Menschen konkret
bedrohen würde ne Menschen abknallen
oder so netten Leute ja noch mehr leiden
das alles fürchterlich nein man macht
den Menschen einfach unfruchtbar klar ja
ein Stück für Stück stirbt der Mensch
dann einfach aus das ist gut für den
Planeten mit Abstand die beste Lösung
das ist gut für jeden einzelnen ja weil
Leben ist sowieso mehr leiden als Glück
und so weiter und das ist eben
interessant was Metzinger ja erzählen
will mit der ganzen Sache ist dass man
über solche Angelegenheiten gar nicht
rational urteilen kann Menschen hängen
an ihrem Leben egal wie beschissen ist
genau und das ist ein Faktor der hier
gar nicht drin ist und man ist sich
selbst unglaublich wichtig selbst wenn
man dem Satz zustimmen würde dass in dem
eigenen persönlichen Leben
das Leiden das Glück überwiegt würde man
trotzdem nicht die Position vertreten
ist besser ich werde nicht mehr da
und das heißt also jede noch so
überlegene Rationalität oder Intelligenz
ja würde bestens programmiert im
Zweifelsfall in humane Entscheidung
treffen
ich meine das ist natürlich da kommst du
zur Ethik zu Moral ja also das ist ein
Thema was ich habe ja auch mal ein Buch
über künstliche Intelligenz geschrieben
vor drei vier Jahren und ich bin mir
einig mit mit vielen anderen Menschen
die sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben
Ethikern die über Computer Nachdenken
über künstliche Intelligenz dass wir
eine Grenze haben müssen das künstliche
Intelligenz keine Entscheidung über
menschlichen lebenswert fällt und keine
Entscheidung die das Schicksal des
Menschen grundlegend beeinflussen
also dass wir sowas was man in den USA
mal gemacht hat auszurechnen mit welcher
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Kind sein aber
nicht schafft ja damit dem Kind dann
anschließend 67,3 als Zahl präsentiert
wird ja und das Kind ist dann ist da mit
diesem sozusagen Maschinen Urteil
konfrontiert das wird dann machen sich
mehr anstrengen oder sich in sein
Schwert stoßen oder sich für dumm halten
oder wer weiß doch kein Mensch ne also
die Tatsache das zu wissen ich meine die
wenigsten Leute wollen die zweite Zahl
auf ihrem Grabstein wissen
und es gibt einfach ganz viele Dinge die
will man einfach gar nicht wissen die
will man auch nicht ausgerechnet kriegen
na du willst nicht deine statistische
lebenswahrscheinlichkeit von irgendeiner
Maschine der sich die dich genetisch und
so weiter durchgecheckt hat und ihr dann
eine Zeit präsentiert und sagt lieber
Markus ich lese hier 17,8 oder so
wichtig also es gibt ja auch ein Recht
auf nicht wissen was habe ich davon wenn
eine Maschine ausrechnet mit welcher
Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Strafgefangener
rückfällig wird wenn er wenn es um die
Frage geht Begnadigung oder nicht jetzt
kommt 52,7% am Ende raus dass der
rückfällig wird ja was heißt das was
heißt das ja morgen wieder eine Straftat
begehen kann das kann auch sein dass es
nie wieder tut richtig also wir
überschätzen so ein bisschen die
statistische Rationalität genau das
woran man sich im Leben orientieren
sollte den Mensch orientieren sie sich
als Menschen an ihrer Tiere so und das
ist ein total interessanter Punkt finde
ich weil genau das tun wir aber wir
begeben uns in die Hände von von ich
habe es mal so gesagt
es kann doch nicht sein dass wir
sozusagen die Welt und die Frage wie die
Welt morgen sein wird das begeben wir
geben wir in die Hände von ein paar
Nerds und das meine ich überhaupt nicht
respektierlich Computer und du hast
gegenüber
muss man auch sagen
genau
wir werden Geschäftsmodell so das ist
das ist genau der Punkt will man das
wirklich das ist die große Frage ich ich
sag dir dazu meine Zahl ab 2035 sagen
Menschen die sich damit besser auskennen
als ich wird es keinen Job mehr geben
der nichts mit KI zu tun hat und das
gilt auch für Tätigkeiten von denen man
das jetzt noch nicht glaubt das kann im
Handwerk sein wo du dann bei deinen
Tätigkeiten von KI unterstützt wirst und
so weiter das kann sein dass die die
Routen des das der der das müllwerkers
werden von der KI geplant und so weiter
es wird kein Berufsbild mehr geben das
völlig losgelöst von dieser KI ist so
ausrechnen wie das in unserem wenn wir
da noch arbeiten was wäre denn dann bei
uns also KI würde uns bei der Recherche
helfen ja würde uns bei der recherch ich
glaube dass zum Beispiel also gerade das
Berufsbild ist Journalisten ist in
akuter Gefahr und es wurde von es war
sehr interessant und da bin ich total
bei Sascha Lobo liebe Grüße an der
Stelle übrigens mit dem Zimmer
wirklich spannend ist sich zu dem Thema
auszutauschen der der schrieb irgendwo
dieser Tage
Springer Konzern ja hat bekannt gegeben
dass man in Zukunft sehr viel auch auf
KI setzen wird und so weiter und dass
man viele Tätigkeiten auch von KI in
Zukunft machen lässt
der Aufschrei ist komplette ausgeblieben
und ich habe mich ähnlich wie Sascha
gefragt warum eigentlich weil was
bedeutet das denn zum Schluss ich meine
an welchem Punkt fangen wir an dann
Artikel zu lesen die nicht mehr von
Menschen geschrieben sind sondern von
einer KI an der Unterschied wäre ein
Artikel zu lesen bitte also bei den
meisten Artikeln wäre der Unterschied
nicht groß richtig also wenn jemand
Agenturmeldung paraphrasiert genau oder
oder
Informationen die weitergegeben werden
von irgendeinem Ministerium oder einer
Behörde einer Institution und so weiter
und die mit eigenen Worten jetzt kurz
und zusammenfasst ob das ein Mensch
macht oder eine Maschine ist auf der
Ebene also sozusagen Bereitstellung von
Informationen total egal weil die
meisten Menschen da jetzt schon quasi
wie Maschinen arbeiten das ist ja
tatsächlich sehr viel Journalismus ist
im Augenblick schnelle geistige
Routinearbeit nicht alle natürlich nein
nicht die bekanntesten Leistungen ist
Journalismus nicht das Moderieren einer
Talkshow z.B oder Kolumnist zu sein an
einer ausgewiesenen Stelle aber ganz
ganz vieles geistige Routinearbeit ja
und wenn man wenn man sich zum Beispiel
also Christoph meine ist einer der
wichtigsten deutschen Informatiker der
sagt es total interessant der sagt
dieses Programm Chat GPT zum Beispiel ja
kann unglaublich beeindruckend und
geschliffen reden
und es wird noch viel beeindruckender
wenn man bedenkt dass es ja überhaupt
nicht versteht wovon es spricht
und das ist ein Punkt das heißt du
kannst ihm Journalismus also ich meine
da gibt es gibt es Dinge die kannst du
auch in der Recherche zum Beispiel
überleg mal du würdest jetzt so sagen
zur Maschine sucht doch mal bitte die
die die ganzen Widersprüchlichkeiten von
Markus Söder die widersprüchlichen
Aussage so im Laufe im Wandel der der
langen Politiker Laufbahn ja so da würde
das ein oder andere glaube ich dabei
herauskommen und das und und die
Maschine würde das komplett in Gänze zu
100% finden ein Mensch ist dazu gar
nicht in der Lage ja das willst die
Frage wer was damit am Ende geworden ist
ne weil wenn ich das dann drucke dann
würde alles das was Markus Söder gesagt
hat was klugweise und so weiter war das
würde dann keine interessieren sondern
man hätte dann nur diese
widerspruchsliste und darüber würde man
sich aufregen jetzt braucht man
natürlich eine künstliche Intelligenz
die diese entrüstungskultur die unsere
Medien der leider durchzieht ja auch
perfekt wiedergibt also man müsste so
ein erregungsalgorithmus da einbauen und
wenn man das machen würde dann hätte man
einen nicht unerheblichen Teil von
Journalismus bereits ersetzt das ändert
aber nichts daran dass es auch sehr
guten Journalismus gibt und das ist zum
Beispiel tolle
investigationsleistungen gibt die man
nicht allein mit Hilfe von künstlicher
Intelligenz machen kann weil es ja auch
viele Dinge gibt die man recherchiert
die keine Spuren im Netz hinterlassen
wo man also tatsächlich Menschen
aufsuchen muss und sich mit denen
unterhalten muss und hinter die Kulissen
gucken und dann Schauplätze gehen und so
weiter das wird jetzt nicht ohne
weiteres alles ersetzt das heißt die
journalistischen Spitzenleistung der
großartig und völlig anders geschriebene
Text die ganz ungewöhnliche
überraschende Reportage ja und die
komplexe investigation diese Dinge
werden nicht durch künstliche
Intelligenz ersetzt werden
weißt du was was ich habe mich dieser
Tage mit meinem Sohn länger drüber
unterhalten der ja mit Informatik
beschäftigt ist wie du weißt und und der
sagte zu mir weißt du wir reden viel zu
wenig über die KI die wir eigentlich
schon haben
und es gibt ja so viele Leute die den
ganzen Tag weil Sie nicht bei Facebook
Instagram rumhängen kontrolliert von
einem Algorithmus von dem die die ihn
programmiert haben selber nicht mehr so
richtig wissen wie eigentlich
funktioniert und das ist total irre aber
diese Algorithmus bringt dich dazu immer
weiter zu scrollen immer weiter immer
weiter den ganzen Tag und wenn du dich
mal zurück erinnerst wie waren es gab so
Gewissheiten darüber haben wir uns
unterhalten es gab so Gewissheiten die
sich mehr und mehr auflösen also
Telefonate kann man nicht Fakten ich
weiß wer am anderen Ende wirklich dran
ich weiß genau wie Papa klingt wenn Papa
zu mir spricht mir ist schlecht geworden
wir haben vor wenigen Tagen Sascha Lobo
in der Sendung gehabt und der hat dann
auf seinem iPhone mal ganz kurz ein Satz
eingegeben über Olaf Scholz und dann
spricht plötzlich dieses Telefon das
dauerte genau 3 Sekunden exakt wie Olaf
Scholz und das Interessante daran war
dass sowas geht das wissen wir
mittlerweile dieses ganze faking und so
weiter aber die die die Tatsache wie das
Ding trainiert worden war das fand ich
irre ich habe Sascha gefragt ob das vor
vier Monaten möglich gewesen wäre und da
sagte nein aber jetzt ist es möglich
dass das Ding kann kann deutsch und und
er sagte das ist aufgebaut auf ein paar
wenigen interview-fetzen die Olaf Scholz
auf Englisch gegeben hat das musst du
dir vorstellen das heißt da werden ein
paar Fetzen von Interviews und wir
kennen das nur weil sie NN und anderen
hat er ja ziemlich beeindruckender
Interviews gegeben auf Englisch und aus
diesen wenigen Fetzen macht dann die KI
heute ein Interview auf Deutsch und es
klingt wie Olaf Scholz und wenn du nicht
ganz genau hinhörst sagst du das ist
Olaf Scholz der dann plötzlich dass das
war sozusagen das dass das ähm
gespenstische daran die macht quasi an
Putin übergibt ja es ist wirklich ihre
man kann nicht jeden überwachen hat
unheimlich kann man gruselig ich meine
das können jede jede Justiz ja kann
Belege fälschen ja auch Journalisten die
jemanden diskreditieren wollen können
das richtig Leute die keine Journalisten
sind aber Reichweite in sozialen Medien
haben können das tun und so weiter und
dann gibt es Millionen von Menschen die
glauben das habe ich doch genau gehört
der hat das gesagt und der das die
anderen wollen das nur verschweigen dass
er das gesagt hat wir kommen also völlig
aus der Möglichkeit heraus Fake und
Realität zu unterscheiden das heißt wir
leben in einer inform
multi-informationswelt wo man am Ende
nichts mehr glauben kann ja ich weiß
nicht sozialen Folgen genau
mit mit mit ihm auch noch mal was
anderes gesprochen er sagte zu mir Papa
hast du mal drüber nachgedacht Demo ihr
habt doch früher immer demonstriert und
er meinte euer eure Welt war doch so
wenn wir ganz ganz viele sind dann
kriegen sie uns nicht so nach dem Motto
die können uns ja nicht alle verhaften
ne hat er total recht und es aber jetzt
geht das Gesichtserkennung das war meine
Spielerei von Apple und mir ging es kalt
den Rücken runter weil ich denken musste
an die Gespräche die wir zum Thema China
dieser Tage geführt haben immer wieder
da gab es ja rund um die ganzen
corona-maßnahmen gab es ja richtig
Aufruhr irgendwann und wir haben diverse
Korrespondenten berichtet auf die Frage
warum ist denn da nicht die ganz
offensichtlichen großen
Verhaftungswellen gibt
man nicht das braucht man eigentlich
kamen Wochen später kam die vorbei und
klopften plötzlich an die Tür und sagten
sie haben doch da und da gesehen da
waren sie dabei hier sind bitte
mitkommen genau aber an dem Punkt sind
wir oder wenn du zum Beispiel Bank nee
auch und sagte zu mir was machst du denn
wenn der Algorithmus dich nicht mag er
meinte wenn du in der in die Bank kommst
und um einen Kredit bittest und der Typ
mag dich nicht dann kriegst du im
Zweifel den Kredit nicht
das Ding ist wenn dieser Mensch dich
nicht mag der auf der anderen Seite des
Schalters sitzt dann siehst du das dann
merkst du das das spürst du du weißt der
mag mich nicht wenn ich im Zweifel zur
nächsten Bank und habe ich das Glück da
sitzt einer der Markt mich aber meinte
hast du dich mal gefragt ob man das beim
Algorithmus so klar sagen kann ob der
mich eigentlich mag oder nicht mag es
kann sein dass der Algorithmus aus
rassistischen Gründen dir den Kredit
nicht gibt weil du zufällig was ich in
Amerika liebst auch vor Amerikaner bist
so es kann aber auch sein dass der
Algorithmus ein ganz anderes Muster
entdeckt hat das mit deiner Hautfarbe
überhaupt nichts zu tun hat das heißt es
kann sein dass die Motivation gar nicht
rassistisch ist sondern einfach was
vollkommen anderes der der hat
herausgefunden da gibt es irgendein
Mustern das passt nicht zu Dir aber was
das genau ist das können selbst die die
den Algorithmus programmiert haben am
Ende nicht mehr sagen und darüber hat
auch Sascha Lobo dieser Tage berichtet
und sagte wir sind jetzt eben in der
nächsten Stufe Auto GPT das ist dann
sozusagen künstliche Intelligenz die
sich selbst programmiert und das ist
dann noch mal eine Kerne vor Jahren von
geredet in meinen Vorträgen wenn es
immer da Irrung ging in Deutschland
braucht ganz ganz ganz viele
Informatiker und ich immer gesagt hat
nein deutschland braucht nicht
wahnsinnig viele aber sehr viel sehr
gute gut weil der Welt und Wiesen
Informatiker wie ich ihn genannt habe ja
irgendwann ersetzt wird denn das
Versprechen der künstlichen Intelligenz
besteht in der selbstprogrammierung
und das ist das logischeste von der Welt
ja also wenn ich ein so intelligentes
kombinationssystem habe dann ist es
völlig klar dass es irgendwann lernt
sich selbst zu programmieren und das ist
auch überhaupt nicht überraschend dass
das passiert und da kann man sich
überlegen dass das auch auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt natürlich starke
Auswirkungen hat also
spitzeninformatiker werden in Hülle und
Fülle gebraucht aber eben Leute die gut
Informatik anwenden können oder einfache
Programmierung machen die wird es in der
Zukunft immer weniger geben ja aber ich
wollte gar nicht so sehr mit dir jetzt
über das Arbeitszimmer da haben wir ja
schon lange drüber geredet dass das eine
Revolution auf dem Arbeitsmarkt sein
wird dass ich worüber ich reden will und
was Du hier angeschnitten hast was jetzt
alles schon geht nein das wird bei dem
Blick auf die Zukunft was ist wenn
Maschinen autonomen werden oder böse
werden wir denken gar nicht darüber nach
was alles schon von KI abhängig ist und
wenn das Störungen auftreten welcher
Form auch immer ob das ein
Programmierungsfehler ist oder willst
zwischendurch mit Stromausfall oder was
weiß ich was zu tun hat also ich meine
wie wir können uns alle ausmalen das ist
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist dass wir in
den nächsten Jahrzehnten keine enormen
finanzcrashs kriegen ausgelöst durch KI
durch Manipulation von KI durch
programmierungsfeder wir haben ja kleine
vorgeben diese Art gehabt niemand darf
sich wundern wenn das passiert bei der
Einsatz von KI eine Hochfinanz ist enorm
wichtig dann alles alle alle Systeme die
irgendwo dranhängen an der
Stromversorgung der Energieversorgung
und so weiter diese Riesen Palette vom
Programmierungsfehler über die
Verkettung dummer Zufälle bis zum
terroristischen Anschlag ja wir machen
uns unglaublich fragil abhängig davon ja
und die Katastrophen die da anzurichten
sind die wären enorm ich meine und das
meine ich mit dem wir haben das Thema ja
schon ganz lange du kennst
wahrscheinlich Siemens das ist ein US
Mathematiker hat Strom Manager einer der
reichsten Menschen der Welt so glaube
ich 29 30 Milliarden Kurzfassung stand
vor vor vom Jahr oder sowas der hat
schon 78 angefangen sich sozusagen von
der reinen Mathematik abzuwenden ist in
die Finanzbranche gegangen und hat dann
genau unter Anwendung komplizierter
mathematischer Modelle seine
Investmentfonds aufgebaut und aufgesetzt
ne das war der Beginn sozusagen dieser
Geschichte die Überlegenheit von
Blackrock ja aufgrund des Systems ja das
also die Finanzmärkte als Finanzmärkte
in einem Ausmaß durch wünscht und uns
kennt und und durchleuchtet und so
weiter und das ist also eine unglaublich
Überlegenheit gewesen
sein eigenes System entwickelt dass sie
über ins lange Zeit eine große
Überlegenheit gegenüber der Konkurrenz
gesichert hat und diesen Schwindel
erregenden Aufstieg von Blackrock
ermöglicht hat mit Friedrich
Spur immer wieder ins Sauerland das ist
einfach
[Gelächter]
mit mit wenn du mit mit
Mathematikern und und Informatikern
darüber redest ich meine dieses Gerede
das seit den 80ern gibt es das
eigentlich die Computer werden uns den
Job wegnehmen die Computer werden die
Weltherrschaft übernehmen und so weiter
ist noch nicht passiert aber was
interessant ist darauf hat mich mein
Sohn hingewiesen und sagte die größten
Veränderungen in den letzten Jahren sind
immer dann passiert wenn die Rechner
entscheidend mehr Leistung bekommen
haben du kennst muss lernen
ganz ne genauso wie es ist so vor ein
paar Jahren ziemlich ins stockenrath
also die Idee war alle zwei Jahre
verdoppelt sich die Computerleistung und
der der der ich an dieser Stelle
genau mit dem Messi auch von Nvidia
Jensen
der kommt gleich aus Taiwan ursprünglich
sind immer Asiaten die da am Start sind
der hat kürzlich gesagt muss raus Tod ja
das war so auch so die Erkenntnis der
letzten Jahre bei weil man gesagt hat
warum soll also welches Gesetz das ist
ja Menschenwerk das zu entwickeln das
kann ja nicht unendlich so weitergehen
und eine Zeit lang sah das wirklich wie
so eine exponential Kurve aus und dann
hat es eine Abflachung gegeben und
wahrscheinlich muss man sich eher die
Veränderung in der Zukunft in Form von
Sprüngen vorstellen und nicht in Form
von Kurven ja ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob er Recht hat ne ich meine es ging ja
immer um die da geht es ja um diese
winzigen Transistoren ne und und ich ich
ich habe meine beeindruckende Zahlen im
Vergleich gelesen du hast sozusagen an
stell dir vorhin einen Daumen Nagel und
auf diesen Daumen Nagel sind dann diese
Maschinen TSMC zum Beispiel in Taiwan
und so oder diese große Chip Firma über
die so viel geredet wird die sind in der
Lage darauf wirklich Milliarden von
Transistoren zu packen die dann rechnen
können und so weiter und das kann man
natürlich einfach rein physikalisch
nicht endlos fortführen aber wenn du
jetzt plötzlich merkst Quantencomputer
die ja so habe ich das verstanden
vereinfacht gesagt nicht mehr
funktionieren über 1 und 0 also Strom
oder nicht sondern auch über alles
dazwischen dann hast du plötzlich an ein
Potenzial das ist gigantisch ja und
insofern ist ist dann die Frage was auf
uns zukommt wenn man wenn man sich die
Frage stellt kann KI zum Beispiel auch
irgendwann wirklich kreativ sein du
sagst ich kann sie nicht es ist eine
Frage sagt kann sie sehr wohl das ist
eine Frage der Definition von
Kreativität also man muss zwei
kreativitätsbegriffe unterscheiden das
wird nie gemacht ja aber ich sehe zwei
kreativitätsbegriffe ich sehe einerseits
technisch mathematische Kreativität
und die besteht im Problemlösungen also
in Mathe ist die Kreativität ich habe
ein Problem und wenn ich das gelöst habe
ja also ein kompliziertes Problem dann
muss ich sehr viel Kreativität aufwenden
um das zu lösen bei dieser Art von
Kreativität steht das Ziel von
vornherein fest
und den spannenden interessanten Weg
dazu zu finden den smarten den eleganten
und so weiter ist die kreative Leistung
und dann gibt es Formen von Kreativität
Open End Kreativität das heißt also das
ist meine Definition Kreativität ist das
was man einsetzt wenn man nicht so genau
weiß was dabei rauskommen soll ja also
wenn wenn Picasso seine Demo selbst von
Avignon gemalt hat dann hatte er so
ungefähr die Vorstellung dass er
irgendeinen aufrührerisches
bahnbrechendes
wütendes Bild malen wollte so das weiß
man auch sehr genau das war das Ziel
aber er hatte ja nicht genau dieses Bild
vor Augen ja sondern er hat ein Jahr
lang daran rumgewerke hält und 1500
Skizzen angefertigt und irgendwann kam
das aber raus was er vorher gar nicht
vorhatte also das gibt ja auch ein
Entwicklungsweg dann hat er seine Ziele
verändert und am Ende kommt dieses Bild
aber raus das ist ja eine ganz andere
Form von Kreativität die erste Form von
Kreativität die mathematische technische
Kreativität da ist KI zu in der Lage die
zweite ist das Gegenteil von
Programmierung
ist eben gerade der gesamte Weg nicht
programmiert wenn ich nicht weiß was
dabei rauskommen soll dann weiß ich auch
nicht wie ich programmieren soll
und deswegen ist diese zweite Form von
Kreativität die menschlichere Form von
Kreativität die nicht ohne weiteres zu
ersetzen ist das bedeutet nicht dass sie
nicht perfekt kopierbar ist also ich war
schon vor vielen Jahren auf
Veranstaltungen wo man mir vorgeführt
hat Rembrandts die in eine KI gemalt hat
Kompositionen die wie von Beethoven
klangen aber von einer KI war
Kompositionen die gar nicht nach
Beethoven klangen aber irgendwie
interessant ja und spannend und man
dachte es den Berg der Romantik das auch
eine ganz normale aber das das alles
sind ja Fakes genau ja das sind ja keine
originellen kreative Leistung sondern
ehrlich gesagt ja es gibt Tausende von
Menschen in Deutschland die können wir
haben
das ist nicht die ganz großen
dunklen kann sondern auch kann Max Ernst
erfinden kann die besser sind als die
Jungs und die Max Ernst dies gibt du
weißt wir haben ja schon mal drüber
gesprochen und sterblich seitdem er für
mich zumindest in der Sendung sagte auf
die Frage ist es nicht mies irgendwie
einfach Leute so zu fälschen und er
sagte bitte ich habe doch niemanden
gefälscht ich habe das wert großer
Künstler ergänzt genau und er kann ja
auch der Satz er hätte nie hat nichts an
seinen Bildern wäre gefällt bis auf die
Unterschrift
unfassbarer Typ ja aber auch so leicht
aber das also das kann man natürlich ja
das kann man natürlich in Zukunft mit
künstlicher Intelligenz und so weiter
auch alles machen
aber wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle in ein
Konzert zu gehen und dich höre mir an
was eine künstliche Intelligenz gemacht
hat übrigens brauche ich dafür ja kein
Konzert ne muss auch keine
Aufführungspraxis haben und so es reicht
ja wenn das aus irgendeiner Box kommt
oder aus dem Kopfhörer
ja das wird ein riesenrolle spielen
schon jetzt spielt es eine riesen Rolle
in der Popmusik ne dafür ist wieder so
eine große Rolle aber wenn man
unterschiedliche innovative Leistung und
sowas machen mich würde das wenn eine KI
das gemacht hat würde ich sofort sagen
interessiert mich nicht egal wie gut
aber was interessiert aber weißt du was
aber weißt du was es ist wie die
Unterschrift vom weltraki du merkst nur
Unterschrift vom weltrake das ist eben
nicht Mozart oder Beethoven ist das doch
der Punkt du würdest da drin sitzen wenn
Dir einer sehr glaubt für dich
versichert und das ist ein ein Spätwerk
von von Beethoven das leider noch keiner
gefunden hat bisher aber wir haben es
jetzt heute Welt exklusiv am Start du
wärst da drin und würdest völlig
ergriffen dieser Musik lauschen und ich
bin mir mittlerweile
gerade sagtest dieses diese kreative
oder Kreativität kann man quasi nicht
programmieren es braucht bräuchte
jemanden der das programmiert das ist
das große Ding da würde ich dir
entschieden widersprechen unser charlobo
sagt das auch die Maschine programmiert
sich selbst und die die sie an den Start
gebracht haben wissen selber nicht mehr
so richtig was die Maschine da
eigentlich macht und dann sagt man naja
aber wir Menschen und diese diese
originäre Kreativität und so weiter und
so fort und dann denke ich manchmal das
ist irgendwie so so vermessen weißt du
wie wie tun alle so als wären wir alle
so unter Mozart Verdacht ja alles klar
aber in Wahrheit in Wahrheit sind wir
alle der Wendler weißt du viel mehr von
uns die er der Wendler sind als Mozart
wirklich kreativen Menschen finden klein
also da brauchen sie vielleicht brauchen
wir nicht lange darüber zu reden
1935 hat Walter Benjamin diesen
berühmten Aufsatz geschrieben das
Kunstwerk im Zeitalter seiner
technischen Reproduzierbarkeit
weiter Benjamin Deutsch jüdischer
kulturphilosoph
dessen Hauptwerk ein
unabgeschlossenes Werk über die
Passagen in Paris des 19 Jahrhunderts
war und der saß aus Assoziationen und
Einsichten und Kritik und alle möglichen
durcheinander so bestand so wie heute
niemand schreiben würde und es wird auch
keiner mehr verlegen und es trotzdem
ganz großartig und dieser weiter
benjamin hat in diesem Aufsatz gesagt
zu dem Beginn als jetzt technische
Produzierbarkeit einsetzte also man
Schallplatten kaufen konnte nicht mehr
Aufführung gehen musste und der Film
aufkam und den konnte man 100 mal
kopieren und so weiter das sagt das
künftige Zeitalter wird ein Zeitalter
sein wo man das alles mit Hilfe der
Technik machen kann die Technik wird
sozusagen die menschliche Kreativität
langfristig komplett ersetzen also deine
und lobothese ja aber dann hat ein
wichtigen Satz dazu gesagt und sie wird
dann keine Bedeutung mehr haben
das mag sein die Cola sozusagen wird
Bedeutung wenn ich nicht kein
unterhaltungsfunktion ja aber keine
gesellschaftliche Bedeutung mehr haben
also wenn alles inflationär und auf
Abruf und maschinell und so weiter
machbar ist entwertet sich das Produkt
richtig das heißt dann spielt die Kunst
keine Rolle mehr und dann sind die
jetzigen Künstler die jetzt noch
besonders bedeutend sind die ansehen
Kiefers und Gerhard Richters die letzte
Generation der Kunst und alles was
danach kommt ist dann egal
das ist kein schöner Ausblick ehrlich
gesagt wobei wobei ich meine wenn du dir
heute mal anschaust Richard also nochmal
letzte kleine Schleife
für heute wenn sie mal anschaust völlig
unvollständig diese Aufzählung ja aber
die Tätigkeiten für die Menschen bisher
noch bezahlt werden und die heute schon
Maschinen viel besser und günstiger
hinbekommen zum Thema inwieweit ist KI
eigentlich längst unter uns ich fange
mal an Übersetzungen
Betriebsanleitungen Verträge abgleichen
auswerten Texte ganze Bücher
zusammenfassen Symbol Fotos mittlerweile
Fake Fotos Fotos von Situationen die es
nie gegeben hat Festnahme von Trump zum
Beispiel
Illustrationen Fragen zur Funktionsweise
von Software die dir beantwortet werden
der Excel tabellenstrukturieren
Nachhilfe mittlerweile
Therapie du kannst du kannst in der
Psychotherapie mittlerweile der
Sitzungen mit einem Bot machen der der
schlaue Ratschläge gibt und da würde man
sagen das kann doch nicht sein ein Bord
kann auch niemals so gut sein wie ein
gut ausgebildeter Psychologe und dann
sagen die Leute die sich damit besser
auskennen oh doch mal lieber weil der
Bot greift jederzeit auf das gesamte
psychologische Wissen der Menschheit
zurück während du vielleicht vor
jemandem sitzt der alle zwei drei Jahre
mal eine kleine Fortbildung macht und
ansonsten aber auf dem Stand des
Studiums vor 20 30 Jahren ist und so
weiter also da kriegst du eine Idee
davon dann Videokonferenzen strukturiert
zusammenfassen Werbeanzeigen Kampagnen
erstellen buchen ausliefern Logos
Drehbücher schreiben Musik produzieren
Apps Websites alles programmieren als
für all diese Dinge brauchst du nicht
nur keine Menschen mehr sondern das geht
alles mittlerweile einfacher billiger
besser genau sagst das ist auch das was
mein Sohn immer sagt das das sozusagen
das was ihm daran so Angst macht ist
diese monströse Skalierbarkeit du kannst
nicht mehr so richtig greifen was
passiert da nicht im Hintergrund wenn
wenn du wenn du jemanden brauchst der
jetzt einfach auf Anhieb eine Million
Tweets die alle für Donald Trumps sind
absetzt dann kannst du das in
Sekundenschnelle machen und das kann der
Board sogar ganz alleine machen in
Zukunft das musst Du dem gar nicht mehr
sagen das ist das beängstigende daran
das heißt wir schaffen ja eine perfekte
unendlich langweilige Welt in der
Menschen immer weniger gebraucht werden
und dann kommt die spannende Frage was
macht man dann den ganzen Tag eigentlich
ja und ja die realistische Antwort ist
sich unterhalten zu lassen ja mit immer
ausgefuchst darauf unter anderem durch
KI im entwickelter Unterhaltung also in
Gameplay haben Welten Musikwelten und so
weiter
einzutauchen ne in ein komplettes Meter
Universum ein virtuelles Universum
zwischendurch muss man ein bisschen
essen aber das weiße intelligente
Kühlschrank natürlich genau und der
ordert dann von sich aus schon die
Drohnen die ihn wieder auffüllen und so
ich meine es gibt Menschen die halten
das für das schlafenland und ich denke
immer bin ich froh dass ich dass ich in
dieser Welt nicht leben muss aber das
ist ja vielleicht und das kommen wir auf
den Anfang zurück liegt das daran dass
mein Gehirn sich vielleicht schon nicht
nur über gesund
zusammengeschrumpft ist ja sondern schon
anfängt sozusagen diese alterativismus
ja er hat die Leitung ja also ich kann
diesen Bild nicht so viel abgewinnen
also ich kann dir Ersetzung von
geistiger Routinearbeit sehr viel
abgewinnen ich kann ja Veränderung der
Arbeitswelt dass die Leute das machen
können was du ihn mehr Spaß macht oder
mehr Sinn gibt finde ich großartig
werblich für finde ich alles toll aber
so das so alles was so das Leben so
ausmacht ne das ist dafür so eigentlich
keine Menschen mehr braucht
Flüssigkeit genau multipliziert
das wird zu Aggressionen führen zu
Überdruss zu Frust zu Depressionen zu
Aggressionen und so weiter dafür ist der
Mensch nicht da wir sind so
bewegungssoziale bewegungstiere ja wir
gieren im Augenblick nach Bequemlichkeit
aber wenn wir das kennst du sicher auch
noch so als Kind wenn ihr den ganzen Tag
verdaddelt hast ist wahrscheinlich in
deinem Leben schon lange nicht mehr
vorgekommen in meinem auch nicht aber
ich kann mich wunderbar in der Pubertät
oder Kindheit daran erinnern ja wenn man
heimlich irgendwie zu viel Fernsehen
gesehen hat oder wenn man den ganzen Tag
irgendwas gespielt hat oder so auch
süchtig war und das toll fand und so
aber wenn man dann abends so ins Bett
ging er ist von mir so leer und
ausgelaugen so doof ins Bett gegangen
wenn man den gleichen Tag 30 Kilometer
durch die Berge gewonnen hat ist ja dann
hat man noch Heißhunger gegessen und ist
glücklich eingeschlafen und ich habe so
das Gefühl dass so dieser dieser Reiz
der Bequemlichkeit im Augenblick ne das
können Maschinen machen muss ich muss
mich nicht einmal anstrengen ich muss
das nicht muss das nicht machen und so
dass der sich am Ende in einem
irreparablen Überdruss recht das ist so
ein bisschen meine ARGE Befürchtung ja
da gibt es ja auch interessante Studien
dazu das ist gerade Jugendliche sagen
sie sie werden depressiv die werden
traurig exakt das was du beschreibst und
die die Frage sozusagen des
intransparenten Algorithmus und ich
glaube das ist ja eher das Thema ich ich
finde ja also das ist ähnlich wie bei
mobilen Endgerät das ist ähnlich wie
beim bösen Internet ja wenn man das wenn
man das richtig nutzt
wie großartig ist es dass du sozusagen
die ganze Zeit das was du gerade wissen
möchtest dass deine Lieblingsbücher
deine Lieblingsmusik du hast es alles
immer dabei und sagt mein Leben muss ich
wirklich sagen enorm erleichtert und
auch bereichert in gewisser Weise ja
genau so mal ganz schnell in meinem
Lieblingsbuch lesen muss dafür nicht los
und sagen wo ist die nächste Bücherei
wenngleich es mir in der Seele weh tut
das ist die Bücherei dann wahrscheinlich
so in der Form irgendwann gar nicht mehr
geben wird das auch noch mal ein anderes
Thema aber das hat das Leben bereichert
und die Frage ist doch eigentlich nur
die nach den Regeln das ist das was mich
so
beschäftigt Twitter hatte vor längerer
Zeit ich weiß nicht ob du das noch
erinnerst eine Kontroverse weil der
Algorithmus Rechte Inhalte besonders
gepusht hat ja ja es gab eine Studie die
gesagt hat dass der der Twitter
Algorithmus rechten Content deutlicher
mehr pusht als linken und liberalen
Content ich glaube
genau und das war der Moment in dem Elon
Musk glaube ich beschlossen hat ist zu
kaufen ja
zwei Dinge sind das so interessant
Richard die Studie hat Twitter selbst
den Auftrag gegeben das ist denen
aufgefallen und das einzige Land in dem
es sozusagen diesen rechtsstrallt nicht
gegeben hat offenbar war Deutschland ist
total interessant seit der Guardian so
berichtet und ich ich ich fand das
spannend weil also einmal Deutschland
also du merkst da gibt es sozusagen bei
uns eine ein sehr viele einfach das und
diese in diese Richtung zu hetzen das
hat natürlich was mit unserer Geschichte
zu tun und das andere aber und das ist
das ist eine gute Nachricht und das
beängstigende ist dass Twitter selbst
diese Studienauftrag gibt weil ihn das
erstens gar nicht klar ist und weil sie
zweitens offenbar irgendwie mal
versuchen müssen zu verstehen was da
eigentlich mit ihrem eigenen Algorithmus
passiert jetzt gibt es ja schon lange
die Forderung dass diese Algorithmen ja
transparent gemacht werden soll das
widerspricht natürlich wieder schlecht
natürlich völlig dem Firmengeheimnis ja
weil wenn jeder seine grandiosen
Algorithmen Transparenz Rezeptur ist ja
genau ja und Tesla genau erklärt worin
sein Überlegenheit in seiner technischen
Ausstattung besteht und alle anderen
freuen sich drüber und kopieren ist am
nächsten Tag das heißt also dieses
Mittel steht ja in marktwirtschaftlichen
Gesellschaft überhaupt nicht zur
Verfügung Gerichte das kann man ja gar
nicht machen dann ist immer die Rede von
Ethikkommission da kann man eine Million
Menschen reinsetzen die da ewig drüber
debattieren und dann kommt der nächste
Entwicklungssprung richtig außerdem
müsste das was so eine Ethikkommission
dann irgendwann mal beratschlacht hat
erstmal in recht übersetzt werden was
noch mal ein paar Jahre dauert das heißt
also die bisherigen Möglichkeiten die
wir zur Verfügung haben um irgendetwas
einzudämmen zu kontrollieren und so
weiter die greifen ja alle nicht mehr
richtig was ist mein Thema und und damit
meine ich weißt du also sozusagen
abschließend noch mal dich die Frage
Richard weil das das ist ja faszinierend
worüber wir reden aber es auch die
Faszination ist Grauens über die reden
wir auch ja also und um nicht so so so
kulturpessimistisch da jetzt raus zu
gehen und apokalyptisch
an Dich die Frage sozusagen wo ist der
Ausweg wo ist die Lösung weil eigentlich
sind wir uns doch eigentlich dass das
großartige Werkzeuge sind die uns da
plötzlich zur Verfügung stehen die ganz
viel stupide Tätigkeiten ersetzen werden
und so weiter und das diese diese
Quälerei von von vielen Jobs die die
wird es so in Zukunft glücklicherweise
an vielen Punkten nicht mehr geben aber
wo muss man eingreifen wo muss
die Hoffnung besteht darin wenn man sich
andere technische Revolutionen anguckt
die erste industrielle Revolution ne hat
dann stellte sich die Arbeitsbedingungen
vor haben wir schon häufig drüber
geredet 80 Stunden in der Woche mit 35
tot ja ein Arbeiter in einer
spinnenfabrik in England 1820
so sieht das heute nicht mehr aus das
heißt am Anfang kam die neue Technik ja
und jetzt konnte man Maschinen machen
wieder am Anfang die Spinnmaschine dann
kam vieles andere nach und man hat den
Menschen vollkommen da eingefügt
gedankenlos um der maximalen Profit aus
der Sache zu ziehen und irgendwann wurde
der Kapitalismus humanisiert noch in der
zweiten industriellen Revolution also
1900 rum Fließbänder und so ja man denkt
ein Chaplins Film modern times ja der
Mensch eine Rädchen im Getriebe es geht
überhaupt nicht um Menschenrechte
einförmigste Tätigkeit ja total
verblödet ja körperlich anstrengend
geistig stupide und heute haben wir eine
Arbeitswelt die sehr sehr viel positiver
ist die eigentlich die schönsten
Arbeitswelten sind in den Menschen je
gelebt haben also es ist ja eine große
fortschrittsgeschichte aber am Anfang
wenn die technische Revolution kam
dann hat das immer ein unglaubliches
Elend oder was bedeutet das war immer
ein langer langer Weg bis man gelernt
hat human mit Technik umzugehen jetzt
könnte man sagen das haben wir ja in der
Vergangenheit auch geschafft das
schaffen auch in der Zukunft die offene
Frage ist nur die Entwicklung die wir
jetzt haben ist unkontrollierbar und sie
geht sehr viel schneller
das heißt also die Frage kommen wir mit
der gesellschaftlichen Humanisierung von
Technik folgen noch mit
oder wächst uns das über den Kopf die
kann ich nicht beantworten aber Angst
macht einem die Frage schon
okay Richard ich glaube viel viel
positiver wird heute nicht mehr und
optimistischer ich danke Dir sehr das
war ein vieler Hinsicht mal wieder sehr
anregend mit dir zu reden wir hören uns
nächste Woche ich freue mich drauf gerne
ja ich freue mich auch drauf tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]